hey everybody thanks for your patience
and if you guys could just stand up here
for a minute to let some photographers
to get where
okay thank you I think we'll get started
with Duncan I have to apologize fluid
from options yes everyone's been so nice
they've been feeding me talking a couple
hours ago they came with a delicious
little chicken sandwich of coffee a
little sweet German I wanted to start by
asking you and all the sweet nectar of
ago they save it oh yeah sometimes how
the fighters can make the best films
about America so what did you miss to
that is because it implies that you kind
of come into America with a specific
viewpoint or a specific take on the
country that you want to explore well we
just kind of want to make it kind of
crazy anarchic comedy you know and yeah
there are a satirical aspects to the
film and that's the subtext you know on
the face of it it's meant to be a good
time sort of fun movie hopefully the
more times you watched a film you
realize there's more things going on and
why did you want to
in Mexico tax breaks who's now I do I
wanted to be on though in the southwest
on the border so busy you know Texas or
New Mexico and I wanted the kind of feel
of the contemporary Western so that was
the main visual element and you know I
knew that you know you because of the
light there and everything and the kind
of whole wide screen look of the place I
knew that would be a great counterpoint
to when they take off to Iceland which
is or Chile blue you know so there's a
visual element as well and Alexander
it's really refreshing to see you in a
company is it as fun as it looks making
a comedy or is comedy harder I was very
very excited I haven't done a comedy in
ten years and then I was in London
shooting Tarzan which wasn't a comedy
and it was very kind of all-consuming
very intense experience it was an
incredible experience but it was it was
very intense so when I got the script it
was just very refreshing to you know
page one like he hits a mine with seals
his cocaine strung throughout the movie
a slumming character right now now but
it was it was almost like cathartic
experience done I've been trying to find
a comedy for four years but it's just
been hard finding I'm not a go-to guy
for for comedy writers so I was very
excited when I got this opportunity and
I thought it was just my type of comedy
my humor that was really Reverend
I've been weird and funny for both of
you what is it about bad cops that we
love as an audience why I guess you know
this film is the reference is the 70s
and American scene one the 70s and they
were kind of all bad cops at that time
really although they kind of had a heart
of gold eventually but these two guys
don't really have a heart is just karate
I guess my main reference was French
Connection
I mean gene Hackman's Popeye Doyle isn't
a very nice person I mean I wasn't gonna
lie but got memory things no he's pretty
racist abuses his authority and he given
opportunity so it's kind of the
reference in that idea and you know as
we see from news stories every other day
now there are quite a lot of bad cops
around so it's never been a guy pleasure
did you watch any old buddy movies cop
movies - um no but I agree with John I
was who's not a fan of the old like the
70s cop movies and especially French
Connection and that showed us we need so
yeah there was a British show similar
yeah yeah we cut up there was a really
good TV channel it did a cut of all
these seventies cop shows
and it's basically them jumping out of
cars punching people you know kicking
doors in and that was sort of
encapsulated everything we wanted
well Alex wanted to jump out of a moving
car it was a bit too dangerous oh yeah
we had a great idea they always think
they never parked their cars they just
jump out but I wouldn't know the idea
was that the jump out of the quarry
there it would be there so my tribe
tribe said and I know I was gonna go out
and go straight into a walk so it would
be like if I'm on the passenger side
that's Mike pulls up I like open the
door
storm walking repairs and hitting the
stops amazing car became a it was it
looked very graceful and it was kind of
[ __ ] but the idea you can imagine how
awesome it would have look it's like you
go straight into yeah we could have had
you jumping up over the bombing that I
guess we could have done that you know
we just dive over the bonnet of the car
talking about it give me what we come
out you know when I slide over yeah I
guess I fail that as well I'm kind of
[ __ ] that's like there it keeps sliding
off why don't we open it up to some of
your questions and people have a
microphone do we have a microphone
and Christian can you be loud and then
one yeah absolutely it's Christian house
from Hamburg Germany and freelance
journalist there's you didn't work in
Ireland
there's no brendan gleeson but you still
decided to stay true to your favorite
genres so what is it that you like I
wanted my dad taught that you pick the
different genres well it like a
depressing black comedy yeah that comedy
for example yeah I mean I guess there's
always dropping the films I do but I
don't think I'd ever made a film within
that humor in it I mean I like
straightforward dramas but I always end
up finding them a little bit too pompous
in you know in real life there's always
company in our lives there's always
drama and there's also comedy and if you
get rid of one of them you kind of been
a little bit pretentious you basically I
see a lot of that you see a lot of felt
especially during awards season and
they're saying this is a really serious
film and the reason you know it's a
really serious Jamaican film is because
no one's gonna say anything [ __ ] funny
at all
I say you know it's a serious movie and
my thing is like well why can't you have
jokes it would still be a serious movie
so those those well I attempt to do okay
Mike
I create a classroom German movie
magazine and so what was the biggest
challenge during shooting the movie
well I guess you kind of he's his moral
compass is completely off on he's a
horrible cop but I don't know if you've
seen the movie but towards the end of
the movie you kind of have to like the
guy enough to root for him and his
colleague when they go off to kill all
the guys that are even worse than they
are so I can establish something we
thought a lot about figurin finding that
balance of making him crazy and horrible
in many ways but likeable enough to free
to root for him towards the end do you
like most I really enjoy being a drunk
on screen and in a real life it's hard
to do good drunk isn't it how do you
know these very few putting one hand a
great drunk performance it's one of the
most difficult things to do like you
know convincingly if you've had a lot of
experience of being drunk you kind of
suss it out quite quickly when people
aren't doing a problem
I remember Robert DeNiro and the last
type hidden' did a good drunk Act
they're not very popular film yes is
very few and far between it's a
difficult lines across actors often go
too far reading well the trick is to try
to be sober because that's like when
you're drunk you know I mean you still
try to keep it together Michael Caine
said on educating Rio that you know a
drunk tries to walk in a straight line
yeah drugs dumb stagger they don't in
their mind ever think they're walking
straight and that was his concept about
Claire a drunk is that you're trying
the Australia Tama impact on backstage
magazine online has meant in front of
young people a question for both of you
how did you road up that chemistry
between you Alexander and and micro
panel did you go on drinking tour spend
together
you can drink too much because you are
you still working out on Tarzan of
finishing stuff uh probably no not
really
why I'm just a very very serious
diligent actor John so when I work I
don't play usually the most enjoyable
thing for me on a movie is drinking with
the actors I mean if I could not make
the movie of preferred not to if I could
just keep drinking that's why I got the
job you sold me if you're on a clip on
YouTube of me drunk I have a big
football game yeah that's bleeding on
the chair in the crown yeah and the
crowd that's Terry yeah so that's uh my
advice to young actors out there how did
you prep with Michael oh did you guys
spend a lot of time together now we
didn't I didn't like I was a big fan I
think Michael is incredibly funny fun
but in a very subtle way I think he's
brilliant and also very good dramatic
actor so I was a fan but I didn't know
him at all and we didn't really have
time to just suspended we didn't spend
much time before we actually met and
Alburquerque about what ten date when we
started yeah if we did three or four
days went through the script yeah
well John how did you know these two
could complete leap of faith but you
never know you know you you can see
actors on the screen new you know
married to each other don't know
chemistry you know you never know anyway
and then there's other figure you hear
about who apparently you would have
arguments all the time but their
chemistry is gross you know you've never
gone oh one way or the other
but I go once we were going through
discreetly like a feeling you know two
guys were pretty easy and relaxed at
each other so that was a good style you
know but then you never know what's from
them I was gonna pan out I've always
been very lucky with cast in them yeah
because I've worked where they've always
been great and I've never had trouble
with anyone really it's me again and my
question goes to Alexander I mean you've
been on a show for work very long time
how did you experience the period after
you've been free to choose other
projects what one might think you feel
free but where there the opportunity see
we're looking for or to the verge of
typecast you as sexy vampires or how did
you experience this period after I've
been very fortunate even while we were
shooting I was on this show for seven
years and I felt like I got some I got
we had five months off every year and I
got to play a very different character
from area every single hiatus in
projects and collaborations that are
very different which is obviously what
you're you look for as an act
you want something that feels new when
exciting bit of a challenge on so I
didn't feel that I was typecast or
pigeon homeless as playing a vampire
were playing a character that's very
similar to erudite and I'm it's
bittersweet like I had an amazing time
on the show I miss my like family like
the true blood family on and kind of
going through that growing with the show
together was an incredible adventure and
experience so on I miss them a lot but I
was also very ready to move on I felt
like seven years of playing the same
character is you still have to you
always have to find something you you
need to learn and discover new things
about your character on because that's
what's fun you know like when you're
like oh I didn't expect that seemed to
take this turn or I didn't think my
character would do this but you discover
something every day and that's kind of
easy if you do a play for a couple of
months or if you do a movie like this
was like two and half months but when
you just play the same character for
seven years and you do like 80 episodes
it can easily become monotonous and you
feel like it's repetitive and and that's
kind of suicide in a way creatively
where because then you know it you're
bored and if you're a bored the audience
is doubling before so that was an
interesting challenge to kind of make it
feel fresh and ocean to me and I think
after seven years on I was just decided
to you know be in control of my schedule
to be able to take time off when I
wanted to take time off and do a movie
regardless of when and where it shot for
70 years I was like fingers crossed I
can squeezes into my window that
and many times it did work and I
couldn't do stuff so I don't know what
I'm talking about right now it makes
sense to us no it was kind of short like
between six and seven months so we had
like there's a really nice job cuz a lot
of people on shows that were it's like
10 11 months and then that was short
frame so I had enough times to warn me
two movies every is plus go home to
Sweden see my family I'm Greg Alva from
the real rejects is a YouTube channel my
questions for Alexander first off I've
seen every episode of True Blood and
without a doubt you and Stephen water
were my favorite characters on the show
so it's awesome to see starting movies
right now my question was more about
your preparation process for the
character I was curious to know how did
you prepare for the character and I know
a lot of times actors come up with a lot
of character background that you might
not even get to see in the movie itself
or portrayed is there anything you
wanted to share that we might have have
been able to see in the film itself no
not really I was it's all about if
you're expending it's you know flying
attacked like the creativity starts that
you're excited if you're and if you feel
this was something it was so different
from anything
read before and I was like I mentioned
earlier you so excited to a comedy if
been I did a comedy in Sweden like ten
years ago and once he once even zoom I
heard fifteen years ago remember I
haven't done much so that was I was just
so excited and again back to being
almost a cathartic experience after the
intensity of Tarzan it was so fun to
just like go crazy and let loose and run
with it on and I've never played a
character like that before and that I
always find it hard to talk about my
process because I what I do is I read
the script once a day for the like of a
month or two before I shoot the movie
and every time I read it I come up with
new ideas new thoughts or a way out
might want to play a scene or if there's
something I want to maybe change I'll
you know call John about it and then 95%
of my ideas will be [ __ ] you come up
with a link that yes but then you kind
of hopefully find 5% of leads that's
good and that becomes kind of the
foundation for the character so that's
kind of always my process I just sit and
read it and think about stuff and then
discard all the bad stuff and find those
little movies thank you John do you
encourage people to improvise at all
long sentence I encourage it but I don't
mind it when it happens if it's good I
think I think the thing with
improvisation obviously is that the
characters have to be good enough at
this have to be so in tune with the
characters that the improvisation comes
from an actual real place and they've
got the text they can always fall back
on where you find in a lot of movies I
think with so called improvisation it
ends up with people shouting each other
punching fridges having how they do that
where they hammer on a car
and they dated and that's improv I'm
improvising now filming missed our wheel
and it just ends up and people shouting
each other so I think what was good
about this the way the dialogue was
written it was kind of written provides
a great way in the sense that both Bob
and Terry is so close though they almost
know what the other person is going to
say and so there is a basis there that
if even the guys come up with in the
additional line it kind of it works
because of that foundation I do I'm not
a fan of film as that improvised on this
table but that's the concept we're gonna
this is a vague idea of what the scene
is and you guys just improvise I'll find
that I always find those films are quite
a mature issue there were strip was so
good and the dialogue is so spot-on like
like you don't want to you don't want to
mess with it it's like that kind of
banter back and forth and you know it's
always me it's like a symphony
yeah we do the rest of the doctor are
you gonna make any I would love to work
in Swedish again it's been a while
doesn't mind you get sent a little
script so the people think oh he's gone
now he's not gonna come back
I don't know they don't really send you
that much
they probably say you think I'm [ __ ] not
a [ __ ] thing you won't read them
oh my
oh really well I was in Sweden to
impress over the summer and I was I was
really pandering I was really I love
sweet nothing loves working no it's it's
son I would love to work in Swedish it's
been a while and there's some really
interesting filmmakers there now you
only have the old botanist downscaled if
you saw a post else can you write your
own scripts okay you write your own
script how do you usually work I mean
did you ever consider scooped you didn't
write or how do you write I mean is it
hard or is it easy or do you work at
night or in the morning or how do we
have too much and why do you write well
it's funny because I'm getting to the
point now where I don't arrive original
screenplays anymore
I just went up because I find it's too
much boring work you basically you're
sitting alone in a room for four hours a
day it's really boring I think about
exciting so I'm moving to write an
original screenplay now I just want to
find books where other authors have done
all the work first and then I'll just
sit down the good dude I mean it's not
you know it's not even want to work at
all German I don't know work at all
that's what this evening towards trying
to save up enough money to go and retire
to Australia the space nearby about the
age of 55 so I've got about six years of
it I just I wanna engage anymore with
anybody taste when I was young he was
the only thing I was any good at jobs I
didn't want to do anyway
but what I consider the scripts yeah I
do but I find that other people don't
write as well as I do I know that sounds
really arrogant especially in Hollywood
you get a lot of really bad scripts
every now and again you'll get a set the
script which has got a great idea
that has never been that wasn't properly
exploited and where I was as I got said
by those once and I did a rewrite on it
but my comedy was too extreme for the
producer and he said never go but to get
it through all over
were you gonna direct it well no it was
a writing job but I was so happy with
the work I've done that want them on it
too directly
I'm not really like because I could
really big-budget action comedy so what
happened they just grabbed it it was
another that was it was a well-known
producer who's made really well-known
films and he basically said to me John
you know the type of movies I make which
I can never make this script because
it's too computational
was too far gone I was a bit funny
stripper you don't get it's funny I
can't I get money for it you couldn't
find another home for at a coyote went
releasing I want to Chuck but it was
well paid but yes I would consider other
people scripts it's just I it's quite
high standard you know any actor will
tell you you get specifically American
scripts are all written as if by a 24
year old virgin who's just got out of
USC film school and they live in Orange
County a really bad tile and the guy
wrote is called Zac something and I'll
pass on the title page about I'm not
reading the script because of at our
place why why Zac wrote it that's AG
something wrote it I'm sorry I'm not
gone I'm not gonna do it and it's always
[ __ ] something I'll give them a break
and you go now it's crap it's always
practice never surprises you but it's
like a lot of them have read yes no
don't they kind of seek the cab this is
like a screen reading book so it's very
they've all read the manuals it is yes
you know it's too early surprise plane
you know it's quite the beef like that
now this can happen end of Act one and
there we introduce this character and
here's the villain and here's that auric
and that's the now we have the conflict
so it's on it's always finalizing
something there to believe that's
different and they always got about the
lead characters like he's 30
he's devastatingly handsome they never
go he's 50 he's as ugly as [ __ ]
why bother trying that bit in I was in a
happy scripts to read II read a ton our
agents sort of went all the pile down
before they get to your depth I'm on I
try to read as much as possible yeah
they yeah they'll they'll go through it
and if they shall do not and that's what
I told them excellent if it's from any
Zack don't even bother that's kind of
the only criteria if it's not what's
that called more than happy to read no
but it's like it's good because
sometimes so I did a movie couple years
ago called divergent girl that was my
neighbors friend wrote the script the
first time filmmaker like less than a
million dollar budget and my name was I
gave my friend Martin wrote the script
she has never directed anything not even
short but I think she's really thousand
you want to read it and I loved it and I
had the most amazing experience working
on it and Mari is one of my best friends
now so you know it's it's it's it's good
to kind of be out there and read smaller
interesting things not sit and wait for
your agents to send you big-budget
movies by exact I think your time for
one more questions
how about without them writing your own
script Alexander and doing your own
movie we have seen today a new
McGregor's first their actual film maybe
it could be something for you learning
from John being his little paragon you
know
well you and I actually wrote and
directed a short film in Sweden 12 years
ago
it's called to kill a child and my kid
brother played the lead and he dies
spoiler alert wrap up by asking you both
of you what you're each working on now
will you have to work together again we
haven't well work together again
hopefully I'm doing a good start doing a
HBO miniseries of fine I think a
episodes and I've got two American
scripts sort of percolating the various
stages planning to work more in America
then well you know I'm actually from
London even at my family's various I
mean the two films are made the
government Calgary the third part of the
trilogy I might write that next summer
I've kind of got most of it in my head
but that would mostly be set in London
I'll be the final sort of thing with ACC
that I'm saying this is like there's so
much work it's already upsetting me
right
yep sitting to run the radar on a
episodes gonna have to write this bloody
screenplay and then make the bloody
films when do you think you can retire I
was as well I was hoping for fifty five
six years or that would be enough yeah
hopefully that will be enough
GSS numerous it's using I started but I
don't know if my liver has been six
years you see how it goes my liver
but now I've become progressively more
bored we direct them the more I've done
it with life in general that's why I'm
hoping my liver so I want it to be a lot
of anymore oh yes I'm on I just got to
Berlin a week ago something they're
prepping a movie called mute by Duncan
Jones yeah
and it's about a mute bartender whose
girlfriend goes missing and he it takes
place in Berlin 30 years in the future
there's kind of a dystopian dark
futuristic world and he's ex-amish and
can't speak and changes through the
streets of Berlin to find his girlfriend
so you don't speak at all no no but and
then we did a couple of last week we did
a couple of screen tests with girls and
[ __ ] it's hard tonight speech I was like
I got it and then it would it I felt
like my instinct was always to say
something and then I had to kind of
suppress that but by I realized you have
to come up with a whole lot cuz he's
been it was in an accident when he was 9
she couldn't commute for 30 years so his
instinct wouldn't be to say something he
would you know obviously come up with a
completely different language with
different way of communicating so it was
this weird feeling but I had to fight my
instincts constantly and I was terrible
um so this it feels great but starting a
week and have no idea what I'm doing
no see
and will you to be taking an Oktoberfest
tour of Zurich tonight
tomorrow morning maybe be you're away
tomorrow a week are you away tomorrow
tomorrow
no we fly to London tomorrow afternoon
right now I'm just I've got the next
thing today
oh you're going Tuesday oh yeah fly back
tomorrow whew we're gonna do that in a
UK London and Dublin we're doing that
premieres this week so machine we're
gonna say we're gonna save ourselves for
that yeah and I was will see me night I
went all-in yesterday an invention thank
you so much thanks for your questions
and just to remind everybody and the
green carpet for a lalala and starts and
15 minutes or less so hard over there
but thank you so much thank you time